[Music]
all right now to you thanks for doing
the podcast great to be here yeah it's
nice to see you again we have we've
crossed paths a couple times over the
years I went to college with your lovely
wife yes and I think I think I said this
to you in an email but Amy I have this
it's weird how memory is bizarrely
selective but I have this very vivid
memory of being in a class with her
freshman year and there was an
assignment to do something creative and
I made this photo exhibit I went
downtown into San Francisco and
photographed all these homeless people
and I blew up these photographs and
mounted them and was really the first
thing first time I'd ever done anything
like creative like I was always very
much like a bookish person and I just
remember her being so kind and and
considerate like she had all these nice
things to say about it and it stuck out
I think it still is in my memory because
it was really the first time that
anybody had had like put wind in my
sails for anything creative that I've
done and it's always stayed with me it's
bizarre
well I had a similar conversation with a
one of my first writing teachers in
college recently and because I had I
have like a a you know there's not one
specific memory except for the fact that
I was in a creative writing class in
college at little school in upstate New
York huh and I was like trying to do
this thing and writing like bad short
stories and I'm sure he knew they were
bad but he he was nice enough to be like
you know these aren't all bad
there's something kind of good here and
he said it in such a way that it was
sort of like he was giving me permission
to pursue something that I really liked
and gave me pleasure and I think and
that really like stuck out well my mom's
like an aunt is it Mike Weiss writer of
what he loves
that's a first what are the podcast I
spy finder modeling on the microphone
yeah well they know I probably know that
that I'm a huge Charlotte's Web a fan so
they know that they're in safe hands all
right now you won't get bit right but I
the but that idea that someone like
gives you permission to do the thing
right that you really like I think
that's that really stays with you and
it's important and I think as you go
through life and as you sort of mature
in your career if you pass that on to a
younger person who you see sort of
fighting with something and trying to do
something and just trying to and working
really hard at it I think it's a really
like valuable yeah that you can do and
they're really small gestures that to
the person giving it might not seem like
anything but can make all the difference
and person's life and people come back
to you like years later and they say
like I remember when you said to me and
you get you know yeah I'm sure Amyas
know right recollection right have no
recollection of this but you know things
stick with you um that when they sound
right and when you want to hear them
there's sort of these yeah helmets we
should probably point out I mean Amy you
know is this uber successful publishing
executive she's done pretty well I mean
I know it's generally amazing what she's
created and I remember her as being like
really smart and intellectual and savvy
she had this like like New York cool
about her kind of intellectual girl from
New Jersey telling her she had New York
cool sophisticated you know what I mean
and and so it's no surprise to me what
she's been able to create and do and I
guess she's probably most well known for
discovering big little lies and the help
right like she published both of those
yeah those are two big ones on the
fiction side last year she did Jim
Comey's book which was an experience
yeah I will say that and she like she
created her own imprint at a very young
age right which was like highly unusual
yes it was there was a time when you
know there's there's certain directions
you can go and
publishing business and that was one
thing she wanted to try and I believe it
was Putnam less the company that said it
gave her her own imprint so yeah on the
spine of many books says Amy Einhorn
books it's pretty cool yeah she since
his move to another company yeah
Flatiron books now and has done a lot of
great stuff there so does she do you go
to her to review your work like being
married to somebody who's in who's an
editor it's great
well it's great for me I mean I mean
she's not the publisher of my books
obviously but you know every it's funny
a lot of people asked me and they asked
it in the context of oh that must be
really hard you know sharing your
writing with her and her going over that
and I mean I've written two books now
both times did the exact same thing
which is before I turned in the
manuscript you know like she got the
first draft uh-huh and you know tore it
apart right in her way and people said I
was that really difficult and my
reaction was why would it be difficult
like here's the person who loves you and
once nothing but what's best for you
yeah and she's actually really good at
this thing she gets paid to do it and
here she is like and who else's hands
would you rather yeah yeah of course
situation so you just sort of go I mean
you go and you let yourself be
vulnerable you know that's okay like you
need help but we all need help this is a
but you're both running and writing
people see as very sort of solitary
activities but they're both I think can
be very collaborative arts and at least
when they're done well it takes a team
and having your wife on your team
helping you along the way and saying you
totally lost me during these 20 pages I
have no idea what you're talking about
you know that's something right I take
to heart and gonna be say okay why well
here's what I was trying
get out there and she's avoiding you
know well you failed in that spot it
didn't work it didn't work and you say
like okay great let's try it again yeah
you just have to have a healthy ego and
you know check yourself a little bit I
would imagine
but nobody's gonna put the amount of
care into it you know than her like
there's this idea that that when you
publish a book you're gonna be having
these midnight three-hour conversations
with your editor over philosophy in life
and it just doesn't work that way I mean
I don't know what your relationship was
or has been with your editor of this
book but editors are busy and with the
consolidation of all these publishing
companies they're like project managers
they're handling so many books and no
matter how much they care about your
book they're they're distracted by all
the other things they have to do yeah
you're one of the you're one of a bunch
of authors and you're one of a bunch of
books that's being published and you
know I think it's always been that way
where you know people turn to read to
turn to other writers and said you know
can you look at this for me does this
make sense is this work and and then
once it's sort of ready to go out the
door you feel like it's gonna put it's
enough it's in the kind of shape to go
out the door then you'll let it go out
the door I mean I know Amy would never
have let me put a manuscript out into
the world if it just wasn't up to the
right standards if it wasn't doing what
it was supposed to do and I'm pretty
hard on myself too I have this massive
fear of boring readers
it's it's a big ask I think these days
with so many distractions to get people
to read you're a thousand word stories
much less read you're a hundred thousand
word book so you got to put every effort
into keeping the story moving keeping it
going keeping them turning pages and I
feel like I'm a pretty good judge of my
own work at this point on when I'm
falling short I don't know if I'm my
biggest critic but I'm up there mm-hmm
yeah I had a Kelly Corrigan in here
yesterday who's written a slew of
New York Times bestsellers and she said
something almost exactly the same what
you said like if you're going to ask
people to read your book like you better
have shown up for the page 110 percent
because it is a big ask in this
distracted age to ask somebody to sit
down and and spend that kind of quiet
undistracted time with something that
you poured your heart and soul into it
takes a little while and I'm kind of a
slow reader so it takes me a while to
read books and it's just it's hard to
get people's attention you know these
days well you did a great job I love the
book it's definitely not boring it's a
page today I'm not done with it yet but
I'm well into it and I really enjoyed it
and that's what we're here to talk about
today we're gonna talk about running
we're gonna talk about this book and I'm
interested maybe that the launching
point is just to ask you like why you're
like first of all why what drew you to
writing a book about running to begin
with and how and why did you laser in on
this character Bob Larson as a
protagonist to tell the story you wanted
to tell well I'll deal with the first
question which is what drew me to one
write about this and that's really I
think the question that's been sort of
battering my head the last I don't know
5 10 years or something like that I mean
I've been a runner for let me do the
math 35 years or something like that but
the question that I've sort of been
going back and forth is I've always
wanted to get at the idea of you know
why do we run you know what of all the
activities we could do why do we still
do this thing and we haven't had to run
for our food for a long time now since
we became an agricultural culture and
yet we still do it and people have sort
of never stopped doing it obviously they
do it in much larger numbers now and
wear fancy clothes when they're doing it
in fancy shoes but what's going on with
us when we go spend
three miles or five miles there eight
miles or 250 miles running at a time
what are we running to what are we
running from runners spend a lot of time
alone often and we have a lot of time to
think and I think that's one of the
reasons why running sort of lends itself
to some pretty good writing at times and
so there was I always wanted to write a
running book about some of these things
but I didn't I didn't really want to
write it about myself I didn't think
there was anything particularly
outstanding about my life as a runner
and it's outstanding to me but I didn't
know how to I didn't think Mike I had
your own person yeah I didn't think I
didn't think I could you know my I
didn't think I could carry a whole book
and all my ruminations about running and
so I was always looking around for the
right running story that hadn't really
been told yet and I also have always
been fascinated by the early days of
long-distance running and when I say
early days it really wasn't very long
ago right when we talked about it you
know the first running boom was like in
the 70s and the running culture back
then the sort of roots of running a lot
of it was very sort of rebellious very
countercultural I mean the first sort of
poster boy of running was D free
Fontaine who had the moustache in the
long run err and that's what everyone
wanted to be like that was that was what
running was it wasn't this mainstream
activity that was on the cover of
magazines and it was it was really sort
of very niche and very fringe and there
were a few things more rebellious that
you could do than wake up on a Saturday
morning and go and run 20 miles yeah
you'd be the freak on the side of the
road yeah it's it's crazy to think about
that because it wasn't so long ago and
now to reflect on the fact that running
is like the most popular participation
sport with you know hundreds of
thousands of people doing Mareth
in some city every single weekend but I
have a very like romantic notion of
Prefontaine and pre Prefontaine era of
these bearded guys with mustaches in the
early days of Nike with the waffle shoe
and no GPS watches and just ragtag you
know dudes who are essentially hippies
like out there doing something on the
fringe like there's something just super
punk rock and cool about that it's great
if any really I mean you say I mean I'm
sure it was a little different in some
ways because you also had like Billy
Mills who came out of the Marines and
you know they did some running in the
you know in the military so you had sort
of that wing of it but a lot of what you
just described that's kind of what it
was
you had these it was it was very fringe
and so I've always sort of liked that
idea and then I've always known I've
known Bob Larson his main character in
the book for a while because he I knew
him as Meb Keflezighi coach right was
how most people know him or maybe some
people out here knew him as the longtime
UCLA track coach but I never really knew
his backstory into one I got invited to
a documentary about him that was made by
one of his former runners and it told
this story I sort of had this mention of
his origins which was with this group of
like we said these kind of hippie
runners in late 1960s early 70s San
Diego called themselves the Hamal toads
and this group of runners who sort of
come out of nowhere to win the 1976
national cross-country championship back
when that was just about the biggest
race other than the Boston Marathon
uh-huh and these were his lab rats like
these were the guys that that he used to
come up with his theories of how to run
far fast he had done a lot of thinking
about it but it was gonna take
experimentation and he came along these
guys and he was working with them for
years in terms of sort of figuring out
his
right and so I and I just really loved
that story and I and then I saw and I
saw a picture of these guys too and
there's a picture unlike yeah was three
of the book right because that was the
picture when I just remember sitting and
watching this documentary and I saw that
picture and I thought oh who the hell
are those guys
yeah I got it I gotta find out who those
guys are
and I thought if they're interesting
that might be a good story cuz you need
good characters right and I started
calling them the maker of the film this
guy Robert Lusitania was incredibly
generous he said that would be great if
you wrote a book about this here's all
my friend's phone numbers uh-huh and so
I called them and you know each one had
just a great story I started asking them
know why do you why did you run
something like if they had a really
boring answer to that first question you
would think well maybe there's not a
book right let's to see how they respond
to that right and not one of them said I
don't know it's just something I was
kind of good at and I just sort of did
they all like had thought really hard
about what they were doing out there and
they all had really sort of visceral
emotions about how it made them feel why
they were doing it what they would been
trying to accomplish and where it had
sort of brought them in life and I think
each one of those had you know some
reason something that they were like to
go back to a point you made a minute ago
they were all running from something and
running towards something yeah right
it's the answer to that question is a
combination of both of those things I
think with most people most people I
would think if you're the kind of person
who's I don't know if you you know I
guess the glass glass half-empty person
if you you're neurotic or if you are you
know self-conscious and self-aware and
you like to think about these things
then yes there's often an interesting
answer right so at this moment in time
the US was certainly not known as any
kind of big running power right and 170
well no like it that the
at the beginning of like this journey
there wasn't a lot of science and
understanding about how to train nobody
nobody knew I don't think people had
ideas but it was one of those things
that it was all it was all well he did
that and he won a gold medal so we
should do that right but no real thought
it was very little science behind it
very little experimentation and that was
the thing that really sort of separated
Bob Larson early on from everybody else
because he he ended up at San Diego
State University and iego for the most
part started in Minnesota on a farm with
no running water and no electricity
family moves to San Diego when he was 11
years old and so he grows up in San
Diego ends up at San Diego and runs in
high school ends up at San Diego State
and it's running at San Diego State and
is really interested in physical
physical education and what we now call
kinesiology and ends up getting to know
this professor named Fred cash who is
doing some of the first studies on human
cardio health because at the time when
we talk about running not being
something people did he was just didn't
exercise I mean the ideas adults so the
idea it was thought that if you strained
your heart after the age of about 35
that was like a very dangerous thing for
you that was the sort of risk massive
cardiac catastrophic events ha ha and so
nobody I mean you think about that and
this was not very long ago there's just
like a little more than 50 years ago
maybe 50 years ago and at that time you
know we're sending rockets to them you
know we're sending people to the moon
where the Russians actually have a
cellphone at this point you're they have
it they have invented a phone that can
fit in your pocket so it was sort of
like the first cell phone I mean the
modern map of Europe was kind of laid
out like modernity had happened and yet
when it comes to a cardiac health we are
in the complete dark ages I think to me
it's completely baffling
and so then there's this guy Fred cash
is doing this studies and he's having
these adults in San Diego come a few
evenings a week to San Diego State and
he's telling them to run and he's taking
there and he's measuring their heart
rates and what he's finding is that the
more they run the more their heart rates
are going down that they're become that
their hearts are becoming more efficient
and Bob at the time is a college runner
and he's training in summers and in
summer as he does this really radical
thing which is he goes and he runs on
trails and he runs on roads cuz he's not
running around the track all the time
and he does that and he then he's
working with Fred cash and looking at
this lab and he has like this aha moment
where he thinks yeah that's actually
what I'm feeling I feel like the more I
run the longer I run the more efficient
I feel the better it is
it's so hilarious because it's so
self-evident and obvious now to think
that that was not something that people
were aware of at that time I mean like
Salk had invented the polio vaccine and
yet people didn't realize the heart was
a muscle like any other muscle like you
know do bicep curls your biceps get
bigger but work out your heart it might
die I think it doesn't it doesn't make
sense but that was the idea no the heart
is just a muscle like any other muscle
exercise it and it will become stronger
and it will become more efficient so
conventional wisdom at this time pre you
know this epiphany was for track and
field athletes well or cross-country
athletes just go to the track and do
what I mean how are they training at
that time you basically had two sort of
amino call them schools but one of the
schools was really like very much in its
infancy that would be the the Lydiard
school lyddiard was this coach from New
Zealand who Bob Bowerman at at Oregon
we're going to visit and had come back
with with or Lydiard has the first sort
of job
grupe mom in New Zealand put and his
idea was volume you know run you gotta
run more than a hundred miles a week but
it wasn't really focused on intensity he
was mainly focused on the volume and
well his mantra was trained on strain so
then he had that school on the one side
and then on the other side you had the
sort of traditional europeans emil
Zatopek was their hero because he's the
only guy the one the 5000 the $10,000
marathon in the Olympics and Zatopek and
all the sort of Zatopek disciples were
obsessed with intervals so that was go
to the track and do half mile intervals
or quarter mile intervals or you know at
the most three quarters maybe everyone
smile you'd do some mile repeats but it
was largely you know Zatopek would do
these these crazy quarter mile training
sessions where he would do like 60 or 65
quarter miles all of them in like 65
seconds with with you know a minute rest
right in between and so Bob comes along
and his idea what he eventually happens
a bond is a sort of middle ground his
two questions were why do the long runs
have to be so slow and why do the
intervals have to be so short what if we
try to go hard for a long period of time
what if you go to what he starts talking
about as your threshold your edge go to
that spot right before you're gonna
become exhausted if you go at that pace
for too long time and try and stay there
stay there for a mile today stay there
for a mile and a half tomorrow and
slowly build up and that becomes known
what we all call today is tempo runs
right sort of lactate threshold training
that moment that place where if you go
any harder it's unsustainable but if you
go just a little bit easier it's just a
little bit too comfortable like finding
that edge
and training at you know at that for as
long as possible I'm trying to expand
your ability to maintain that pace right
and it's uncomfortable I mean the idea
is worst right you're at if you're at a
place you're at a place where you're not
comfortable but the idea is to teach
your body and teach your mind really how
to be comfortable with being
uncomfortable and and that that's okay
right it's okay if you're afraid you're
not gonna die it's okay if you're afraid
of it because we're all probably afraid
of it it's not you know it's a learned
behavior to go to the place that makes
you uncomfortable and to stay there and
to think don't slow down actually try
and go a little bit faster see if
there's one more click I can get to and
that was really that's sort of the
central revelation of what he had his
runners doing and it was all measured I
mean he would taking their pulse rates
it wasn't he would have groups of
runners he would he would do you know he
had a control group and then he had the
experimental group and he take their
pulses ahead you know in the middle of
their runs he would see how much how
much they were straining how much these
guys were straining and they would look
at the results and who was getting
better
uh-huh and that's what he came upon so
his his methodology he was seeing he was
seeing bigger gains and more compressed
periods of time than control groups or
people that were training in accordance
with these other methodologies
definitely yeah it's interesting because
all three of those modalities there's
wisdom to all of them I mean the sort of
initial you know volume you know concept
I mean that's sort of the legacy of that
is kind of the math atone method like
that's I trained with that like all the
time like building building that
efficiency from the ground up as opposed
to the top down which is what happens
when your threshold training and the
interval training like now I feel like
in modern times the best you know
approach I mean depending upon distance
and you know what level you're at is
some combination of all of those yes and
that's the thing you have to do I mean
now everybody says you
you gotta have three elements to your
training you gotta you know you have to
have you got to have volume you got to
have you know those threshold runs or
I'm sure if you're cycling same thing or
if you're swimming the same main
threshold swims and then you have to do
you know some of those short intervals
the workouts and stuff you don't have to
build build it from all three but while
you're doing that if you're interested
in distance running if that's your thing
the intervals probably shouldn't be too
short
yeah and the and the long runs shouldn't
be too slow if you have go I mean if
your goal is just to finish then you
know close you want who cares
I mean but if you are really focused on
or even slightly focused on improvement
and getting faster and I'm and I will
say I've never met I've never met
someone who ran a race and then didn't
say I wonder if I could do it fast
uh-huh that's just like a very I just
feel like that's a human it's a very
human thing and so is so if you ever
have that that thought I mean that's the
kind of thing I'm speaking to here right
that drive that we have well the other
the other radical thing is that he did
that Larson did is he took them off the
track which at the time was an athame
right like every day you're supposed to
go to the track and try to be better
than you were the day before just
hammering these repeats on the clock and
I know just from my history of being a
swimmer like that that it there's a huge
mental toll that comes with that because
you know you're in a swimming pool it's
a fixed distance there's a pace clock
and if you're not hitting these repeats
at times you know that are better than
you were the week before or even the day
before you start to think like am I
making any progress like it's very hard
to you you just can't go hard every day
and there was a period of time where
that was the philosophy just go in and
just like go as hard as you can every
single day and for him to take these
athletes off the track
get onto the trails you know you don't
really there's no GPS washes they don't
know exactly what pace they're running
and just to learn how to go on feel and
practice these surges and being at that
you know that edge had to be some mental
reprieve well the track and the pool
probably is really really good for one
person
and that's the coach because lockers can
stay we can stand in the middle of the
track or it can stand on the pool deck
and can have the watch and they can
monitor everything and you know he or
she is not the one going around in
circles like a hamster all afternoon or
going back and forth in the water all
day and driving those hey you know good
going going slowly going mad but when
you get off the track or you get out of
the pool it's just I mean for obvious
reasons it's liberating
yeah you feel free you can go you're
going from point A to point B and the
good thing about Bob is that he started
coaching when he was really young so you
know this first team of runners he
coached at mana Vista High School in San
Diego you know they show up for
cross-country practice on the first day
and they're looking around for the coach
and the windbreaker and know he's
actually the guy wearing shorts and a
t-shirt running shoes and he says let's
go and they run together and he was
running with his runners you know until
he couldn't keep up anymore right or
even and even even when you know he was
in his 30s and certainly slower than the
people that he was training you know he
would run the first he would run the
warm-up with him they would run the
fight at first five six miles with them
and then let them go he was like a 420
miler yeah right at one point it was a
420 miler
and a twenty and a 24-second 200 runner
and he's had some wheels but you know he
so he would sort of build that trust
equation that way and you know he's
still he's eight years all these store
runs he lives on you know he lives on on
top of one of the Brentwood Hills and
it's it's about two miles up the hill to
get up to his house and I was sitting on
his deck with him last night having a
beer and he said and he says yeah it's
however workout I did it a couple weeks
ago uh-huh
and I sort of said you ran up the
helical East guys like oh yeah it's
pretty cool that's awesome
like he's still run and he still runs
most days usually drives his car down to
the bottom of the hill and runs on the
flats but I mean it's that idea that he
runs you know straight up Tigertail Road
or yeah I know that deep it's pretty
darn steep yeah and when he was coaching
UCLA he would on Sunday mornings he
would tell his runners you know run up
to my house and you know they'll be
pancakes waiting for you and did it sort
of as bonding but also it was good he'll
what does he what does he think of a
book like he has to be thrilled uh he it
took it took some getting used to for
him he is you know he has these he has
these um Minnesota roots and when I was
where I was working on this book and I
you know from the beginning and you got
to sort of figure out what the book is
about and you have to sort of figure out
you know we sometimes we call it the
mule you know who's gonna carry the book
huh who's the character is gonna carry
the story and that wasn't immediately
apparent to me in terms of how it was
gonna be structured you know I thought
maybe it would be about all these
different characters and it is about all
these different characters but at some
point it became clear to me you know
what this story needs to stay as close
to Bob Larson as possible
his story he's the only guy in America
who was present at the birth of the
running boom the collapse of American
distance running and the person who
brought it back herself cetera and
resuscitated it and you know that's
really like an incredible story and
that's what sort of the book was about
but in the same way you know he I don't
have any business relationship with him
I was just interviewing him along the
way and I wasn't sharing drafts of it
with him so I mean Billy being the
Oakland A's president yeah if he didn't
know Moneyball was really about him
until he got sent you know a galley an
advance copy of it and it all shocked he
was a little shocked that he was the
main character and so then when I sent
it to Bob once it was sort of in book
form I sent it to him to have a look and
also I needed I needed him to fact check
to make sure I wasn't getting stuff
wrong I it took a little he was sort of
a little surprise and he was a little he
was just sort of take he was just he's
just not he's a very humble person the
reason nobody has heard about him is
because even though he would have had
every right to 25 years ago or however
many years ago when he's producing like
gold medalist after gold medalists to
have written a book and called it the
Larson way or something like that and
gone on any number of talk shows or you
know gone on the circuit and become a
franchise into himself
he's never thought of he's not the kind
of person who would ever think of doing
something like that so it was my great
good fortune that he's sort of this
unknown guru of American songwriting and
twos little so he loves the book now but
it took him a while to get used to it
right is he doing like events with you
will he come out and yak about this time
he was with me last week we did an event
with New York Road Runners and I were
while I'm in LA we're doing something
with
la running club and south bay runners at
one of the schools in Santa Monica
during their weekly workout uh-huh and
so yeah I think he's having a pretty
good time with this it's a bit of a kick
for him my my favorite part of the book
is is just the the kind of Bad News
Bears
story of these toads right this ragtag
group of young runners who you know
don't sort of cut the cloth cut this you
know image of elite athletes and how he
shapes these young minds and athletes
into into Champions and the story of
them going to the au Championships
without any money and you know they show
up they don't really have uniforms or
indeed only this shot of water kind of
thing I mean how can you not like reap
for these guys that yeah that's what it
was when they have no they had been they
had been turned down by the early
version of Nike Bob knew Jeff Hollister
and it said I got a pretty good team
here can give me some money to get him
to Philadelphia and he said who's on the
team and he's basically said yeah not
really impressed I've never really heard
of those guys sorry
not into it uh-huh and yeah they were a
bunch of they these were not like the
elite of the elite
look they were fast there were some good
they were great natural runners and they
had good careers you know ed Mendoza ran
at 210 marathon in Boston on a really
hot day and he was on the Olympic team
in 1976 so there were some good runners
there but they weren't sort of the blue
blood mm-hmm runner in terms of they
weren't the sort of chosen the chosen
ones who I'm sure you grew up with those
guys in swimming you know they're really
the guys who are always good as
teenagers and some of them go on to be
very good as adults and also just the
these they're these programs that you
know like oh well the good people come
out of these programs like in you know
and running it's Oregon or
what have you there's certainly you know
that exists in swimming and here you
have you know Larson with this with this
group their unknown they're not there's
no legacy now he was it was at Grossmont
junior college right that's where they
are that's basically where most of them
started Grossmont Grossmont junior
college in you know and san diego he was
only allowed to you know the community
college system you aren't allowed to
recruit you you it's like a public high
school your district is drawn and he
could draw kids from eight schools and
eight high schools in the region and of
course once he had some success and
people start like moving into the region
so they can go and run and run for him
but it was basically whoever shows up on
day one right and of course he would
look in the local high school scene but
his recruiting amounted to he would have
a barbecue at his house and buy a keg of
beer and invite the local track coaches
over once a year and say like so who do
you got who's coming in who should I
keep my eye on yeah that was it and they
came to him but they worked differently
and they worked harder and so he would
show up to these Invitational meets with
all the big four-year schools and he was
back they were better than that they
were beating they were beating all of
them because they were just because they
had happened on to that the sort of
secret sauce and talked about them as a
team I think we mentioned before and
that people think of this as a very sort
of solitary activity and individual
sport but you know we talked about
Larsen's first principle of going to
your eggs the second one was you got a
train you cannot train alone like you
are you are part of a team the group is
more powerful than the individual you
lean on your teammates they will pick
you up on the days when you are slacking
off when you're falling out of the pack
you're gonna try and run harder to keep
up with the pack and you know tomorrow
you're gonna be the one that's leading
the pack and someone else is gonna be
falling off and they're gonna try and
keep up with you it's a you know it's
like they
I've mentioned that it's like the
peloton in cycling you know you're just
that big clump it's really powerful I
mean there's aerodynamic reasons and
cycling lights really powerful but
psychologically it's really powerful -
the last thing you want to do is get
chewed up and spit out and ride behind
so there was that idea and then the
third idea was just that where you're
born and how you're born and how you
grew up is not your destiny you can
change your destiny if you do the work
if you do the right things and work as
hard as anyone you can be better
tomorrow than you were yesterday I love
that because it would be easy to say
that his philosophy is lactate threshold
training but in truth his philosophy is
a philosophy of life it's applicable to
running and being excellent in running
but those are principles and rules to
live by no matter what it is that you do
or seek yeah that's I mean that's that's
honestly like that's really the main
thing that sort of drew me to this story
you know I wanted to write a running
book that was yeah it was about running
but you know running is sort of the lens
as a running and writing are sort of the
two lenses through which I approach life
and I don't have been a sports writer
for about 20 years I've been journalist
for 25 years I don't think I would do
this if and I wouldn't have sort of
gravitated towards sports if I didn't
think it had a lot of stories that would
convey sort of these lessons and not
morals and I say that it's ounce or
tough preachy and stuff but I'm very
drawn to stories that can speak to
things beyond the playing field and
beyond the field of competition because
these are the stories that sort of help
me get through my day and I have provide
me with like I said that that sort of
lens of which of which I can sort of
have some revelations and epiphanies
about what's important and how to
approach things
and so in when I'm doing my job right
you know readers are getting that
benefit as well and very Murakami yeah
that's sort of that that's that's the
hope um is to sort of convey that and
hope that people you know if this book
makes you love running and be faster
terrific but if it makes you think it's
okay to be uncomfortable I actually
really want to push myself to a kind of
threshold um whether it's in relation in
my relationships or in my job or even
just you know I want to start painting
I've never painted before and I'd really
like to try that even though I know I'm
gonna be terrible at it then great and
that's that then that would be the the
greatest thing yeah having the courage
to approach that edge and getting
comfortable with being uncomfortable is
where you meet yourself and where the
growth occurs that's where the man I
mean that was the whole idea with wood
Bob when he because where you're when
you feel like you're gonna collapse and
you don't that's where the magic is like
that's where you find truth about
yourself yeah that's where you that's
where you can take that moment into a
race and know that when you're really
hurting you can think back to no not
I've been here I've actually been here
before I can do this I can I can keep at
this for another mile or two and I can
keep up with this guy and it spills over
into everything that you do you know you
develop this resiliency and this
willingness to confront that edge in
other areas of your life and and as a
result your life expands hopefully yeah
hopefully it definitely does and and you
know you just can't you know whether
you're a runner or not whether it's
running or swimming or whatever it is
that you do where you can kind of find
that flow state sense you return from
that
more complete like with clarity that you
didn't have beforehand like you I'm sure
you've never come back from Iran and
said I wish I hadn't done that or you
know some problem that you were
wrestling with by allowing it to kind of
exist in your subconscious while you're
running you come back with a solution to
it and I don't know how that works or
why that works but it works no I
definitely do a lot of my best writing
while I'm running there's no question
about that I can tell you exactly where
I was when I figured out the subtitle of
the book which was it which is you know
a band of misfits and the Guru will
unlocked the secrets of speed I was
having really hard time with like that
verb like searching for the secrets of
speed or searching and then like you
know I was in Central Park and I was
just about on the north end I got a
hundred and second Street and all of a
sudden and I've been thinking about it
for like an hour as I was an hour into
my run right before the hill back up -
yeah right exactly and all of a sudden
it was like unlocked came from me and I
was like yes unlocked and it was there
and you know everybody you know my
family at this point is quite used to me
the image of me like coming back into
the apartment from a run instead of
grabbing the closest pen and paper and
scribbling things down before I forget
them yeah things that I've thought of
things I want to pursue lines and
stories that I want to use just if you
ever have to stop in the middle of the
run to like record a voice memo or
something well I don't want my phone
because I hate carrying things and you
know I run to get away from stuff yeah
especially my phone um and so I got
nothing i got nothing to record on I
don't I don't have a Apple watch I've
had that thing go where I'll have some
idea mid-run yeah and it's like please
don't let me forget this right sometimes
I do you know yes I don't want to stop
and make a note or something like that
I'm sure I'm sure I lose some of it but
I feel like your mind can be a pretty
good filter and if it's really if it is
important you'll remember
if you really or if you play a game and
you think about ways to remember it you
will one of the things you do in the
book is you also weave in your own
personal relationship with running and I
and I like that I mean I think it it it
allows the reader to you know connect
with why you're writing the book and you
know identify some aspect of themselves
in in yourself because you're relatable
in your relationship to running so the
question that I have is that you ask all
of these other people is why do you run
like how do you answer that for yourself
well I mean the this sort of funny it's
funny to me at least answer is I got 123
marathons at this point and I'm grown
like kind of obsessed with trying to
complete that distance as quickly as
possible and see how far see where I can
get to and you know within the confines
of a full-time job and raising children
and reading books and writing books and
so be cut and the reason I thought of
have come upon as to why I'm focused on
my time is because I guess I kind of
feel like if I can keep getting faster
then I'm not really getting older right
or you're not gonna die I'm not gonna
die okay just ridiculous but you know
but it's a fun little game to distract
me from it and it makes us you know it
makes you feel good makes you get out of
bed in the morning so there's there's
that reason it's a little sort of
existential game you know but it's you
know a few other reasons why I run I
just never feel more alive than when I'm
running I never feel I never my thoughts
never feel as sort of ordered there's a
sense of peace that I'm getting even
when you know doing half mile intervals
you know and that dreaded eight by eight
hundred workout right everybody has to
do at some point when you're trying to
work so fast
Michigan 800
yeah they're there cause there's a
there's an editor runner's world he said
Bart Yasso oh yeah actually hundreds
yeah
they really work I mean it's it's
torture
hey I don't know it's curious what
what's the swimming equivalent of the
eight of like the eight hundred is it
100 I mean I think it depends on what
what discipline like what stroke you
swam what your event is I mean I would
do these crazy sets of like 10 times 200
fly that probably would be the most
similar version of that on some level
that's a it's funny he said cuz it
because my 800 time and running
he's about I think my 200 time in
swimming uh-huh so I sort of get curious
and when I'm swimming I'd sometimes two
sets of 200 because I can't run every
day right it's the same on my crotch Jay
it's a similar amount of time you're
pushing yourself but so even when I'm
like pushing myself like that I'm very
conscious of like there is a kind of
piece to this um there's a quiet that
happens and and I think it's sort of
getting to that quiet and getting to
that it's just it's it's just very
elemental you know just you and your
shoes in the road and maybe sometimes
there's 10,000 people surrounding you
but it just it just feels right it's
like it feels I don't want to say I'm
like I am my best self when I'm running
because that would be it just doesn't
sound right but it's one of those it's
one of those times it's one of those
it's a it's a it's a thing that I do
where I feel really comfortable with who
I am and it's other people have other
things that they do where they where
they feel that way and that's a that's a
spot where I'm just I'm just in a good
I'm in a good place
yeah I had an opportunity many years ago
my family we were in Santa Fe just for a
couple days to get away and it was
during
period of time when Ryan Hall and Sarah
Hall were living there and Ryan's like
hey we're gonna be down at the track
like doing it work out like once you
come down and I got to watch him do you
also ate hundreds
while I was like on the outer Lane
plotting doing my eight-minute miles or
track and I just never seen anything
like that like I was just you know
marveling at what a specimen he was
running around the track yeah
unbelievable and his pulse probably what
not gone high yeah yeah it's it it's an
amazing thing but having said that did
you talk to him after and was he like
talking about your running also well
he's a very generous curious person but
you know what an incredibly humble well
one is oh well yes he is all those all
those things terrific person but one of
the things I loved about running is in
the DNA of the sport is there's this
there's there's a not much of a gulf
between the elites and the you know
workaday runners in terms of talking to
each other about what they do there's
this understanding that we're all sort
of doing the same thing in a way that if
you went to try if you were a golfer and
you went to try and talk to Phil
Mickelson and you started talking about
like you know the match you were playing
at your club the other day yeah he would
laugh at you you would like make some
joke about you know your drive or your
putter or something like that whereas
I've been honestly never met an elite
runner who wasn't interested about how
you were training wanted to was
interested in hearing you know how you
felt or how somebody else felt during
you know Boston in 2014 when it was kind
of hot or or in 2018 like what was your
experiencing of it
when it was you know 37 degrees and
pouring rain
it's that's just part of the culture
Adib Raman said to me like last year
when I said like I'll be I'm not
comparing what I do to what you do and
he said I said what do you mean then we
all experienced the same pain we just
experienced it at different times that's
amazing
there's the scene in the book where
where you get a text from meb the night
before Boston your eyes for Neal in New
York yeah and he's like you know
suffering on the horizon tomorrow or
something like anything the pain is in
the forecast for all of us right and I
just thought like how cool is that like
the here's the guy who's lining up you
know for the race of his life trying to
win and and he had the the mindset to
like check in with you yeah and see how
you were doing
yeah that's like and they and that's
just not me and mad because I was a
reporter I mean there's there's you
could find all kinds of people who the
night before the marathon are you know
trading Instagram messages with you know
you fill in the elite runner you know
this is you know they're passing time
everybody's nervous about the race and
you're said essentially that same time
which makes it really beautifully unique
right it's so there's a there's a
camaraderie there we all it make it may
be somewhat rooted in a sort of common
affection for it because being being a
long-distance runner and being an elite
marathoner is a very you know
intentional career choice being any kind
of elite athlete is obviously you're
gonna take a lot of pain and a lot of
suffering but being an elite marathoner
I mean that is a lot of time a lot of
time alone a lot of really hard workouts
a lot of pain and you only get two
cracks at it a year if you don't
marathoner because you can't really your
body can't really perform well more than
twice a year in a marathon maybe three
times in like 14 months or something but
not more than that so the payoff you
know
if it's yeah stakes are pretty high so
to do it you really better love it no
you you you got it's a it's a thing that
it's a thing that you're gonna be
passionate about it so Larson helps uh
sure in this new era of running and
contributes to the boom that we see
occur in the 70s with this kind of
embrace of long-distance running and the
kind of Jim Fixx era Prefontaine and all
of that there's this explosion in
popularity with running but it's not
long after that the United States like
takes this dip right and we kind of
disappear no it's like a dance buyer
like what explain what happened and then
how it was resuscitated because we're in
this amazing period right now where
we're seeing the resurgence of the
Americans on the world stage in a way
that we haven't seen since that era so I
mean it's hard to say exactly what
happened but here's two things that
definitely did have is I mean it's hard
to draw the exact cause and effect
relationship but two things that
definitely did happen one is Alberto
Salazar who you know it's just about the
greatest American distance runner ever
you know one New York three times one
Boston and it's just absolutely flying
in his career in the early 1980s and
everybody expects he's gonna win the
gold medal in the 84 Olympics and
that'll be sort of a crowning
achievement for him and on the way to
the 84 Olympics he essentially just hits
a wall he cannot run fast anymore
he's just he's he's not getting slower
he's not getting faster he's getting
slower and he should be at the prime of
his career he's like 26 years old and I
mean only later would you find out that
you know he was dealing poorly with some
nagging injuries and not getting the
right treatment he was also suffering
from depression so that was a problem
but the
lesson that everybody took from Salazar
and nobody trained harder than Salazar
and Larson didn't train sows I was on
the other side of the country but
Salazar was definitely from the Larson
school of threshold running and he went
beyond the threshold he nearly died in
the Falmouth race and Cape Cod he you
know the the Boston Marathon the one
that's known as the duel in the Sun
between him and dick Beardsley in sort
of this just epic race on an incredibly
hot day and you know he was just
completely fearless and then like I said
he ran into a wall and the Faust lesson
that everyone took from that was he
probably was training too hard he over
trained outran himself you know maybe we
only get a certain number of steps in
life before our bodies start to break
down so don't use up too many of your
steps in training or else you're gonna
be done at 26 is this when people are
starting to realize for the very first
time that overtraining could be a thing
I mean probably that's that's yet
overtraining becomes a big topic of
discussion at that point but in the
long-distance community the idea is
don't overtrain how about we only run
like 90 miles a week uh-huh and we go
back to that train don't strain idea and
I'm not just crazy those operators the
whole thing I mean I think I mean the
numbers of people I mean there were
dozens scores of American who could who
could run a marathon faster than 215 in
the 70s and early 80s and by the 90s
there was like one 215 it's not that
fast miss crazy fast for you and me but
nowadays 215 years three miles behind
Elliot coupe chogi right in the Berlin
Marathon so to give you an idea I kid
you're not it's certainly not
world-class 215
so Bob Larson is sitting there at this
point he's coaching UCLA and as a
college coach he is focused on
recruiting you know the way you win
national championships in college which
is what your your your mission is as a
college coach is you get these very
versatile quarter-mile or essentially
these just absolute specimens who can
run quarter miles they can run 200s they
can run relays they're so fast that they
can if you need them to do a long jump
or a triple jump they can get points and
those events as well so he's very
focused on on those folks and winning
national championships and he's winning
a bunch of them doing quite well and
producing lots of Olympic gold medalists
and he's not so focused on long-distance
running hmm and it's a it's his original
love it's his original passion but he's
not paying that much attention to it and
then he happens upon this high school
senior named Meb Keflezighi
and he has this incredible story family
moved here from Eritrea when he was in
seventh grade and his father you know
was a refugee and escaped the civil war
there so the war with Ethiopia and it
was he's this immigrant kid and and
Larson gives him a full scholarship to
UCLA and brings him there and Neb
becomes you know his vehicle for this
project that's gonna that basically
takes up you know his post-retirement
life from UCLA which is to resuscitate
American long distance running your
meb's gonna be the guy that he he has
the tools he has the discipline he has
the willingness where he thinks he can
he has the talent where he thinks he can
take him and turn him into a champion
it's gonna take some time but what it's
mainly gonna take is it's mainly gonna
take doing the workouts that he was
doing with the Hummel toads back in the
nineteen seventies with one extra
wrinkle which is elevation
and that's because that has become all
the rage and that's what the canyons in
Ethiopians are doing right did he have a
conscious sense that he was trying to
resuscitate American running obviously
see so it wasn't just map he's like we
need to bring this whole thing back and
map is gonna be my cypher yeah he was
horrified by it I mean the 2000 Olympics
he had already been named I think the
distance coach to the 2004 Olympics and
the 2000 Olympics the Americans could
only qualify one man for for that race
in the marathon and it was you know
instead of three spots which used to be
no you it had been in the 70s that had
been like a real battle to get one of
those three spots in the Olympics and
now we couldn't even meet the qualifying
surrender to get to get more than one
person and just to get back to the
earlier question because I said there
was two things that happened the other
thing that happened the eighties was
Sebastian Coe became like the biggest
favorite in run in track and field and
his father wrote this book and a lot of
what Cove what his father focused on
with you know training Sebastian and
raising him was interval you know
interval training and not so much volume
and not so much threshold running even
though Coe had been doing a lot of that
training but just with like a small
group that his father wasn't really
involved with and so that didn't get a
lot of attention so people were very
focused in the same way that you'd be
very focused now on you know how Roger
Federer you know develops his tennis
game right people became very focused on
how Sebastian Coe had become right which
was antithetical to Larson's whole truck
right exactly so in the late 90s when
he's trying to revive this you know his
idea is no and this is also what's going
on at this time is the East Africans are
starting to dominate everything and so
there's these people who are sort of
doing these studies and putting out
these theories about you know well
they've evolved from the Serengeti to
have longer Achilles tendons or
they're muscle fibers are different and
that losing capacity is larger there and
and because they're so thin they're able
to cool themselves right there's all
kinds of theories that are out there and
Larsen's ideas know they're just working
really hard and they're living in the
Rift Valley at 7,000 feet and they're
training in groups and they're doing and
like you know he traveled and got there
know took notes on what their training
regimens were and he said this is what
we were doing they're doing it they're
doing what we were doing though they're
out like I had you you must know Knox
Robinson you know not his own onyx black
roses NYC running club oh yeah okay so I
had him on the podcast and he spent a
lot of time in Africa like hanging out
with those guys and training with them
and he tells crazy amazing stories but
when you were recounting you know the
philosophy of Larson I was thinking like
yeah that's exactly what those guys are
doing they run in a group there there's
a lot of joy there's a lot of
camaraderie they do put in a lot of easy
slow miles that they're running together
and then when they they choose their
moments on the track and when they hit
the track it's like full-on full-on but
they're living this lifestyle at
altitude where there's no distractions
and this is just it's a lifestyle it's
not like what they do when they're not
doing other things and that's not and
and the American distance runners at the
time were training off on their own
mostly at sea level and they just
weren't and weren't putting in the work
and weren't putting in the hard work and
so Larson creates this group called the
mammoth Track Club mainly so that meb
has a group to train with and they go up
to Mammoth Lakes and a camp out there at
8,000 feet and four years later there's
six marathon medals that are given out
every one they don't have to Mammoth
right treating in the snow right but six
years four years later you don't when
there's six marathon medals given out
this little group at Mammoth gets two of
them that gets the silver and Deena
Kaster he gets the bronze and that's a
pretty good ratio for when you had when
you weren't even close to having any
for years before then you create this
little group and over that period of
time these groups start to pop up and
you know Brooks Hansen runners Nike has
the Oregon project and also Schumacher's
group now you would just never become a
professional runner in America without
choosing a sponsor and moving to a place
like where other people are training
when they're like these little fiefdoms
these little cults almost yeah coalface
it sound I don't know it without their
Jordan right without a dejar but it's
like it's it's the training group it's
the gang and they work together
they're pretty inspiring you know Hoka
has a group in flagstaff there's you
know there's a couple there's a few
people still up in Mammoth Deena Kaster
still lives at man with Lexi Pappas went
up there to train with her and so
there's this group there are some
runners that are still up there but
they're you know Alberto has his Oregon
project group and Helene Flanagan has a
group of another group of runners in
Portland and they do altitude can't they
go for altitude cams I think you're
probably better off if you go live at
altitude I'm sort of a big believer in
that right I train low philosophy seems
to seems to work pretty well for the
people who do it I understand why you
wouldn't want to live at altitude just
because there's not a lot of
civilization in America at 8000 feet you
have to yeah you have to it's a
lifestyle like you said there's some
sacrifice involved so Larson takes map
up to Mammoth and at the time he's like
what is he like 39th in the world at the
10k or something like that like he's not
it's not like he's on everyone's radar
is the next great thing when he gets on
the starting line of the Olympic
marathon in 2004 he has the 39th best
marathon time in the field uh-huh
you know there's 80 runners in the field
there's something like that but he's
done some pretty hard work the last year
in terms of getting ready for that race
you know Larson had done large diamond
jovi Hill
he had recruited up to Mammoth the Jovi
Hill was sort of running readers might
know him because he's a character and
born to run mm-hmm
in in the study that he had done a lot
of study of the ultra marathoners and he
had led this team at north adams state
to you know an ungodly number of
championships but he's really sort of
the nation's foremost authority on
elevation training uh-huh
and bob recruits him to run the mountain
Track Club with him and they had you
know they knew that that Athens marathon
course backwards and forwards they knew
the weather they had had meb and dena
training you know in the middle of
summer in black tights and turtlenecks
and hats to make them uncomfortable make
them understand like just how ungodly
hot it was gonna be during the Olympic
marathon and then the the search for the
ultimate ice vest and how to cool them
both Deena and map showing up at the
starting line with ice fest yeah at the
very last moment right it's a gate you
know the his whole theory was this is a
game to keep your core as cool as
possible for as long as posit limiter at
the highest level is it I think it is
yeah there's been Studies on that the
the people that are able to you know
avoid that boiling over point or who are
more efficient or effective at
maintaining a lower core temperature are
able to maintain the efficiency and the
high level output for a longer period of
time but once you kind of tip the scale
and you start overheating and you can't
regulate that anymore that's when
performance declines right so the longer
you can kind of keep that at base level
it's been shown to be a huge factor in
performance I can imagine exactly just
fur I mean I'm the furthest thing from
an elite runner but I mean I melt in the
heat like it's good heat and humidity
it's just absolute kryptonite
affects different people in different
ways yeah I imagine it affects and I
know especially when it affects me which
is I keep getting bad luck or I've had
several your moments of bad luck where I
train all winter for the Boston Marathon
and then I show up at the start line and
you know I'm training in 30-degree
weather in New York and then it ends up
being the first beautiful spring day in
Boston and like today and this year it
was 70 degrees in humid and not a year
before the year before right I ran that
one really was my best racer like 20
mile an hour had 137 degrees freezing
rain that was absolute heaven but but
you know I was in his good shape as I've
ever been this year and I've never felt
more sick in a race and I just I guess I
knew four miles in I was just so out of
breath on this tiny little incline and
it was just it's 20 miles later I was
limping you know basically and I was so
sunburned and I was like a it looked
like the rest of the week that I had
like that first day you go to the beach
in the spring like when you're pale as a
ghost and you come home and you're like
there's fried that's what I looked like
good day after the Boston Marathon so
but yeah it's it the it's getting back
to what we're talking about I mean if
you can stay cool
it's a great thing and he had these
vests at the Athens Olympics that Mebane
Deena were wearing those item ice vests
until the very last minute and now he's
it's ubiquitous you see that you see
Tour de France riders wearing them when
they're warming up before the time
trials like you see this happening you
know across many disciplines of sport
now it's got to start somewhere
yeah but it's amazing when you look back
on it though because all of these things
are very elemental and simple like hey
let's let's seclude you let's put you at
altitude no distractions we're gonna a
hardcore group of people and I'm gonna
be a bit of a dictator and you're gonna
do what I say and you're gonna trust me
and you guys are gonna get through this
together and I'm going to push you
harder than you've ever been pushed
before
but you're gonna be ready and the proof
is in the pudding I mean that's kind of
what he did right yeah it's not that
it's not like he had some super crazy
philosophy about training that you know
I mean maybe it was at the time but it
doesn't feel like it and that's the
thing about running though is like
there's no shortcuts you know there's no
there's it's it's largely about the work
it's largely about patience it's largely
about being committed and that's you
know a lot of this is it's the same
thing with writing too
you know it doesn't come quickly or
easily
it takes a lot it's it can be very
painful right um it takes a lot of being
honest with yourself and true of trying
to do anything well I would think so I
only do two things
I only to really try hard at two things
which is running and right so but I
imagine you know electrical engineering
is probably that way too
I've never I do I do think you know get
getting back to that thing we talked
about earlier about pushing yourself and
doing the thing that's uncomfortable I
have never met the you know really kind
of like happy person peaceful person you
know successful person either
financially or just has done something
really well who has said you know it was
no it was the key for me the key for me
was playing it safe
I'm not taking the rest not taking any
risks right I just never you know like
you never hear that mm-hmm
it's almost always you know there was
this thing I did and I wasn't really
sure but I kind of rolled the dice and
it was uncomfortable and struggled for a
while at it but it kind of worked out I
know so why is it so hard for us to take
risk then knowing that because the
default because it's uncomfortable
because they because we like want
because you want to be at equilibrium
you know right you wanna I you want to
be comfortable you don't it's you know
it's this it's why is it hard to when
you're in a new environment to go up to
a stranger and talk to them and
introduce yourself it's a learned
behavior because that's uncomfortable
that's risk you know it's weird you know
that's and but with you do that you
might make a buddy you know and we know
that intellectually and we know that if
we never do that we'll never make
another friend it's like dude some
practice in the same way that they
discovered the heart is a muscle that
can be trained to be stronger discipline
and your willingness to put yourself in
those uncomfortable positions is a
practice as well you start with small
things you acclimate and then you have
to always be kind of increasing the the
temperature or the volume on that and it
doesn't mean that it necessarily gets
easier but it kind of does get easier or
it just gets or you just you just used
to it you get used it comes of your nose
yeah you sort of understand it and I
love that I mean the thing I love about
I'm kind of a hot yoga addict and a
thing I love about that is that
everything and I guess this is true for
all yoga whether it's hotter it whatever
temperature you're doing that is that
it's always referred to as as your
practice and you know there's no I just
love that idea that it's just end
there's no end it's just practice it's
just your practice you know it was
practice for what well for tomorrow's
practice right right and I feel like if
we it's a good it's a it's a good idea
you're no one gets out of here alive
right also like what are we what are we
doing we're just practicing right you
know we're just just seeing if we can
see if we can figure it out a little
better a little easier a little smarter
and not make the same mistakes because
God knows we've all made a lot of them
well let me know if you discover the
secret which one I don't know wherever
this is all heading
all right well to what do you attribute
this incredible resurgence in in women's
long distance running that we're seeing
now like we're in this golden age right
now where we're just seeing performances
that we we haven't seen in kind of the
history of long distance running on the
women's front in terms of American
performers I mean do you track that to
Larsson as well I mean there has to be
other well I track I track it not so
much to Larson but I track it to someone
that he coached although he wasn't her
main coach Dena yeah I mean it it helps
when you see someone doing right someone
breaks through and does something well
it's sort of like where our conversation
started with it's almost like she gave
fast
young American women permission to
pursue this thing and showed them that
if you can if you pursue it the right
way you can be as fast as anyone you can
win Chicago you can win London you can
be on the medal stand and that really
helps imagine there's a lot more kids in
China trying to make the NBA after Yao
Ming right that really helps so but you
know and that was you were going back
now to her the heyday of her success was
15 years ago but you know what like
Shane Flanagan wins New York in her mid
30s des finally wins Boston in her
mid-thirties you know they had been
close before but if you think about how
old were they when Dena was having her
success that's a you know that's an
influential moment that's an influential
time having said that there is an
infrastructure that has been built for
women to develop and support them to
develop and support them now or the
people who are get pregnant right which
I want to talk about
great series of stories but my friend
like a friend and colleague yes doing
can I just say she's done an incredible
job she does great staff amazing
reporting and it's so refreshing and
great to see interesting in-depth
stories about running in the New York
Times
wow that's I mean I had I didn't have
anything I didn't need to do with the
pregnancy stuff right but she broke
doubts to what I did right but I did
when I got the times in November of 2017
I sort of read her stuff for a while and
she's in a different department she's
not in the sports department so she you
know to lose the use of the loose term
she kind of freelances with us uh-huh
you know one of the first things they
did when I was there is I you know
reached out her and grabbed it for a cup
of coffee and I said you know you're you
have a really good voice and I'm gonna
do everything I can to try and turn the
New York Times sports section into a
runner's world so you've got a pretty
good record there's a lot of there's a
lot of running stories very happy right
I said so it's gonna ask you like how
much of that is you're doing I pretty
much pretty much me yeah and also
expanding that that that lends a little
bit more just to adventure stories in
general like we're going off on a
tangent right now but like Adam Skolnick
reporting on : Oh Brady's Antarctica
attempt was was astounding it's done and
the the amount of of geography that you
that you gave for telling that story in
real time and in depth and and the kind
of multimedia you know layout at least
digitally as well as in print I mean it
was fantastic yeah I mean we take and we
we take a lot of crap from sort of
traditionalists readers fans of
stick-and-ball sports when we do stories
like that like the page woman's crowd
yeah yeah and we take and we you know we
take it seriously you know like we we
don't want to turn off for readers we
want as many readers and subscribers as
we can as we can get you know having
said that
you know if there was a cooler story out
there than two guys ski racing across
Antarctica in December like I want you
to show it I want to show it to me like
come on like what was going on in the
NBA that was so fascinating well like
brick I don't know if there was there
were two guys ski racing across an
article but that's what it was that's
what it was it was it was a ski race
between these two guys across Antarctica
and I mean I'm a huge Nordic skiing fan
as well but we generally are only able
to cover that during the Olympics like
we do occasional story about that but
they're just not a huge readership for
it but that's so he had this race so
yeah so whenever were in whenever these
stories come across our desk that are or
we have these possibilities of writing
about you know big themes big moments
epic battles life and death it's just
stories that sort of raise all the big
questions yeah that's where I want us to
be that's cool and you and Lindsay was
someone that yeah I sort of I really
liked her writing yeah she's and I'll
have to curse on this - yeah she it's
[ __ ] fast she she ran a 257 marathon
and at sea I am in December and she's
she's trying to qualify for the Olympic
Trials which is a pretty huge endeavor
to go from 257 to 245 but she's she's
working at it so and yeah she's super
talented yeah so she broke this story
for people that are listening that
aren't familiar about how I mean you
could say it better than I can but
essentially how Nike was not providing
paid essentially leave for their
athletes on the roster who became
pregnant it was it's almost kind of
worse than that because you know it's
common in the shoe industry
unfortunately to have these reduction
classes and what they would tell you is
well we need them because if we don't
have incentives for runners to keep
running then they're just gonna sign
these contracts and we're gonna have to
pay them and then they're gonna get
injured then they're not gonna want to
come back and they're just gonna collect
our money so we need weed them to keep
performing at a certain standard and a
certain level in the same way that you
know if you played for excuse me if you
play for the New York Yankees and you
know if you weren't playing well you'd
get cut now you probably you'd have a
guaranteed contract if you're in
baseball but in football there's no
guaranteed contracts you get cut you
start getting paid anymore
so they're saying you know isn't it what
they would say it's not different from
that however those contracts they really
even at the highest level you know like
even meb after he won the 2009 New York
Marathon if he had gotten hurt and had
to sit out for nine months they would
you know cut his pay drastically and to
get back to talking about the women
pregnancy was sort of seen put in the
same bucket as injury right or
disability I mean and actually even in
our health care system today I think
when you go on maternity leave after
your pregnancy you go on disability
which is a strange categorization for it
but that's that's the way right but
that's sort of though that's how the
health care system actually deals with
it or at least it was when my wife was
having her maternity leaves and so they
were a quite like I said they were
equate impregnable which is about as big
a disincentive as you can get and it's
really unfortunate it's a real challenge
for female athletes who a lot of them
are sort of you know reaching their
their athletic primes as their
biological clocks are ticking pretty
loudly you know it's it's it's not a
great int of people have
children and flourishing families after
the age of let's say 35 which is when
you see a lot of women retire from
professional athletes I don't think you
would find a lot of OBGYNs to say that's
a great time to think about starting to
have your family my sense just from a
10,000 foot view on this story is that
well first of all there's so many
developments in terms of nutrition and
training technology and money being
funneled into the sport that is
promoting the longevity of these careers
allowing athletes females and males to
compete at the highest level later and
later and later so there was a time not
too long ago where the idea that you
would be you know world class after age
25 just seemed impossible but we now
know that's no longer the case so I had
this thought like well this contractual
provision in these Nike contracts or in
prom value ladies the other you know
apparel contracts or whatever sorry go
ahead
these but those contracts also had
non-disclosure agreements okay so not
only were they in there but the runners
Nike vid protected itself because the
runners weren't allowed to talk about
them because if they talked about it
publicly then I don't know you're the
lawyer right what's the time you know if
you sign a contract and you're not
supposed to talk about it and you talk
about a public publicly well you're open
to damages so he took so you know I'm
sorry I interrupted you but that was the
thing room right when he had gotten she
wouldn't talk about yeah wish I could I
can't imagine how she was able to you
know get them comfortable enough to take
that risk it's being reported being a
good being a really good journalist but
back to my thought I mean I had this
sense that this is probably antiquated
language that's been in these contracts
for a very long time they were drafted
initially when things were very
different and it's just one of those
things where well this is the way we do
it and the general counsel's office or
whoever drafted that just never really
went back and looked at like should we
really still be doing this until it
finally got called
out and from a revenue perspective had
Nike or whoever else was doing this
gotten out in front of it before any of
this happened and said why are we doing
this this is crazy we need to support
our women during pregnancy we believe in
the you know in them for the long haul
from a revenue perspective it's really
not that much money and the storytelling
and the goodwill that they could
engender by demonstrating that kind of
support for the athletes on their roster
would have benefited them in such a
dramatic way but now they can't do it
like now it just it will seem well they
did it yeah they have today they did it
and it's not gonna make anyone feel good
about right they did it you know they
announced it on a Friday I sort of you
know I mean so in that sense it's great
that it's different but nobody's patting
them on the back of course they're doing
that but you know this is and they're
taking a huge hit yeah but this is the
right and and the amazing thing it's a
revenue perspective because I mean we
could it's nothing with three keystrokes
we could you know see what Nikes annual
revenues were last year you know many
many billions of dollars and detracted
what they what they spend on women's
running and the handful of women's
runner he's like yeah Afra is that a
tiny fraction of LeBron James's contract
so we're not talking about a lot a lot
of money there but you know this is sort
of the history of sports of sports and
sports business and that was my story
stroller right my first book was how
sports became a business it was it was
because it was athletes it was not a
bunch of you know white guys in suits
you know coming up with great
revelations about free agency and free
markets and competition and things like
that it was a bunch of athletes rising
up and saying we're not gonna be
exploited anymore and you know what you
want to exploit professional athletes
fine go find them we're not gonna play
right
and then you know owners commissioners
General Counsel's whatever they realized
very quickly that ooh you know if we
don't have the best in the world playing
for us we don't really have a business
anymore and nobody's buying nobody's
buying tickets to the Yankees to see
George Steinbrenner play they're fine
tickets to the Yankees to Ciaran judge
or Derek Jeter play so this is what it
takes it takes you know basically these
athletes rising up and saying no we're
not gonna do it we're not gonna deal
with this anymore and embarrassing them
and shaming people into not exploiting
their labor yeah well I think we're at
another event horizon with this right
now that which it seems like it you know
in the NBA and the NFL with players
getting together and and in a way that
you know is pretty powerful I think I
think we're gonna see some more changes
yeah and certainly from the from the
social standpoint a political social
standpoint I think it's it's very clear
that
yeah they assets have voices and they
have now more than ever right and they
have to be allowed to express those
voices it's you know it's it's really
important and when they when they try
and suppress them it does not go well
right also was it the New York Times
that that that broke this story about
the NBA players who are experiencing
depression because of social media and
all the pressures that come with trying
to you know basically have that voice
yeah the story right I can't remember
who reported that I don't know who
reported it first it's it's been you
know when you talk about um this whole
idea of athletes and depression and
there's multiple causes for it I don't
think it's just necessarily the social
media and having a voice but I do know
that at Stanford for instance they
recently I think they recently
hired a psychologist for just the
athletic department uh-huh home from the
Counseling Center and I had heard that
that person was like immediately
completely overrun with Wow
you know just did not have enough time
in her day to or his day I'm not sure
who worries all of his retreat all of
these athletes and it's just it's a
tremendous amount of pressure at the
high level and I'll put Stanford
athletics at a pretty high level of
performance in addition to you know the
academic pressures that are there but
and these you know it sounds cheesy to
say like they're they're people just
like us but the frailties and you know
the human frailties are not exclusive to
you know journalists and lawyers and
teachers and things like that the women
who play on the women's national soccer
team they suffer from imposter syndrome
they're worried when they step onto the
practice field that the coach is gonna
figure out that they're a farce that
they've been faking it all along and
this is the day they're gonna be exposed
as not as not being good enough not
being fast enough I mean that's that's
as common at the highest level sport as
it is in any other walk of life and then
imagine a top draft pick for the NBA
some young kid who comes into a
ridiculous amount of money is put into
the spotlight you know in a in a you
know in a way that's hard to comprehend
and has the added pressure not only of
having to perform week after week to
keep the job and maintain his position
on the roster but also develop his like
quote-unquote brand via social media
because now everybody has to be their
own brand and the responsibility that
comes with that on top of just being an
athlete and it's not surprising that
we're seeing all kinds of psychological
crises that
you know we're having to confront with
and by the way shoot shoot 43% from
three-point land right or else right now
or else here or else here night after
night after night night after night you
know you hit nothing but net from 25
feet with the clock running and yeah
it's not easy I had a a girlfriend from
college who then things did not end so
well I refuse I go I was in contact with
her and I said I sort of apologized for
acting like an idiot and and she said oh
please if we were all held responsible
for our 20 our 20 year old selves we'd
be completely screwed and it was
honestly like one of the most generous
things somebody yeah has ever said and
you know it's a nice it's a nice way
it's an it's a nice way to think about
like your acquaintances and things like
that or people who were you know jerks
at one point yeah you get older things
are not that big deal but at the same
time you know as a sports writer who has
spent a lot of time with elite athletes
in their 20s who have you know maybe not
behaved great I just imagine what it
must be like we are holding them
responsible for their 20 year old selves
I think we're we're holding almost
everybody responsible now for their
behavior all the time and if you're
20-something everything is now filmed
and documented and shared and we're in a
culture that's hypersensitive that is
holding people to account for things
they did you know long in the past and
that concerns me you know I think we
need to be able to be forgiving of
people and allow them the place to the
space to grow and evolve and when we
can't do that I think we're you know
creating a culture of fear that is
making people you know afraid to connect
with other human beings
among other things I'm just glad I'm no
I'm just I'm just glad I wasn't on film
when I was 24 years old
yes I'm preaching to the converted to
talk to you about is your thoughts on
the sub to our cap chogi thing like how
do you what do you think about that hole
that prot that Nike project where you
know at monza they tried to go under two
hours and how close he's now become you
know getting to that point and you know
how long do you think it's gonna be
before that actually happens well I mean
I absolutely worship kept Jogi quite
scary it's did you go to mom I did not
go to mondo no but at Cesar gave you a
blurb for the book yeah right I think I
have known it for a while and I loved
his book two hours which was really you
know had a lot of foresight because he
he brought the book a couple years
before right before the kept oh he made
that attempt and so yeah I will I will
say that going into that first event I
was sort of dismissive of it but then it
just looked so cool and it was so great
the way you had all these other elite
marathoners supporting it and trying to
make it happen you know forming the cone
around him to try and break the wind and
it it was completely kind of fascinating
and you know he's gonna be as another
the British chemical company is
sponsoring him to try and do it try it
make another go at it and you know if he
does it I won't go in the record books
cuz it's not an official race right but
it's still a completely unbelievable
thing yeah for him to pull off it's just
absolutely incredible and what's even
more amazing is probably the fact that
he's got the world record down to 200
201 30 and a regular you know in a
regular race in Berlin and I don't I
don't really know how much longer it's
gonna be I mean can he can he get there
you know right course right day right
training block
I'm not gonna say no even though you
know if you do the math and he's the
last to go 90 seconds faster and you
know 90 seconds over 26 miles you say oh
it's just you know 4 seconds a mile or a
little less than 46 I'm on your about
like what you ending at the end but when
you read already running it for science
but he's running for 40 he's running for
40 miles you tie and now he's got around
four thirty Six's I mean that's it's
completely insane
so everybody's seen those videos of the
treadmill that they set up at the the
run expose where you have to jump on and
run his pace yeah it's people can't do
it for more than five seconds right it's
completely not possible right it's a
good way it's a good way to break your
neck yeah getting one of those
treadmills so but I love anything that
gets people fascinated with running
movement activity it's it's like I said
it's it's like the most elemental of
sports in some ways I want it to be I
was I wanted to be cynical and snarky
about that whole thing and then I
started watching it and I was like
captivated I was like I similar to what
you said I was like oh no this is
actually really cool like yeah it's a
stunt and all of that and it's a
branding thing and but at the same time
I couldn't help but just be riveted and
amazed and I think he's gonna do it I
think he will it's I'm not gonna say he
won't but I mean it's what does he want
he's won I think ten of his eleven
marathon said he's run right that that's
probably more amazing than even breaking
two hours I mean you just that just
doesn't happen and marathons are like
golf tournaments no Tiger Woods it is at
his best I think was winning one out of
three that he entered which was an
unheard-of rate of success and marathons
you know if you win three or four in
your entire career you're right in the
Hall of Fame and this guy's won 10 out
of 11 of the fastest marathons he's
winning Berlin and London every year he
seems like such a gentleman too
and he's a gentleman yeah and he's kind
of like a Zen he's kind of like very zen
about things he's really supportive
he's never they've never been a whiff of
of drug stuff around him so so when you
lately superhuman when you look at him
how do you account for why he's so great
or so much better or perhaps why does
why wouldn't have you asked Larson what
what he thinks
Kip Jogi is the best well I think most
people for me start with how he lives
and how he works which is here's to the
three he had here's to those of all
three principals and he you know lives
in the Rift Valley and trains with his
group and trains as hard as anybody so
there's that and you know he's blessed
with this unbelievably efficient motor
some people are born you know some
people are born with this unbelievable
motor and you know clearly he's the
complete outlaw he's the outlier of
outliers he's you know he seems to have
the perfect body type right it's one of
those things that you could analyze his
stride and say see it's the perfect
stride but it's also the perfect stride
for the body that he has I'm not sure
you know you and I could do everything
we could we could spend hours looking at
tape and imitating his stride which no
matter we're not gonna run we're not
gonna break five minutes in a while I'm
not gonna break six minutes in a mile if
I do that so but mm-hmm
yeah I don't and that's one of the
that's one of the really cool things
about running is people don't in some
ways people still don't really know
exactly what creates a superhuman like
that yeah
is it was it but that's what makes
sports magical it Canada in the best
yeah and the best of circumstances
absolutely so in the process of
researching and writing this book how
has it affected your own
relationship with running like has it
changed how you train or think about
your relationship to the sport like
definitely PR while I was right out well
I was writing in 2017 which is great you
run with a group I wish I ran with a
group more I do occasionally run with I
do yeah it's one of the things like I
really have to get with because you know
sometimes in New York Times as well
running team that I run with sometimes
sometimes I run I'll run with a friend
and you know put busy schedule stuff
like that children schools dinner it's
things like that sometimes yeah
I can't always yeah I can't miss or
shower at your office can you duck out
and there is no shower at my office I
belong to a gym not far away so I could
but I'm me I'm an early morning your
honor
yeah I go early morning so it's the
start of my day so that's that's not a
problem is but it's just the but
although a lot of running groups
actually in the city meet in the
evenings and that's just like doesn't
work so much for me but there are early
morning running groups that I could get
with the nice thing about running is if
you run you meet one other person you
run within like that's your group yeah
should run with Lindsay yes I would love
well she's on the team that we run
together sometimes and races so that's
pretty cool and if you do you work with
a coach at all or you create your own
training program you know I interview so
many coaches some sort of constantly
trying other things pick up picking up
stuff that's one of the things I love
about my job is I'll do a story and you
know I'll be in Flagstaff for a couple
days hanging out with the HoCo runners
and I'll do one of the you know and
they'll come back with you know a
notebook filled with Ben Rosario's
workouts yeah unless I'll do those for a
month or so or you know hope they have
one of my you know endless conversate
with endless conversations with Bob and
he'll say oh here's one you could try
how about doing this and so I'll do that
just coach you right well he basically
does doesn't realize it yeah so
so yeah so it's in that sense it's fun
make bringing myself open to it's made
me it's made me aware of all kinds of
different training so that's part of it
I will it has recently I feel like it's
brought a certain a little more pressure
than I would like to my running you know
I came out with this running book and
all the said once I was on you yeah well
now it's a I sort of almost feel like
there's this pressure to be for me to be
like this running guy yeah a we could we
could I can relate you can relate yeah
I'm not even on the cover of my book so
so it's so there is that there is a
little bit of sense of is this a job am
i is this not a job that I do or am I
still doing it for my right reasons or
and I am still doing it because I love
to do it but there are it's a we it's a
weird thought process that I've never
had because I've never written a running
book before I how do you account for
this explosion in interest in ultra
ultra running and ultra endurance sports
that we're seeing like this this was you
know talk about another fringe movement
that has really kind of tipped into the
mainstream it's interesting to see these
races go from you know a dozen people
intense you know the night before a race
to selling out and creating all this
kind of you know interest I think it's I
think it's it seems completely natural
to me that I don't know that it's
necessarily people wanting to one-up
each other as much as they want to sort
of one-up themselves what's the next
thing yeah what's the next thing I can
do and then they hear about something
and yeah I'd like to try that also I
think part of it has to do with you know
the country we're talking about us
somewhat rarefied socio-economic set
when we're when you're in that group
yeah there's a fair amount of disposable
income available to people
and that seems like a cool way to a cool
way to do it I think social media has
some element of it you know now now
there's the you know there's the ultra
you did but it doesn't actually exist
until you post about it right and then
your and then it exists yeah so I think
people want to you know people people
are really into into that part that self
promotion aspect you know to it and you
know there is a certain group of people
for whom there's a limit to how much
enjoyment they can get from their mobile
device or their computer and you know
who just want to get out and push
themselves and do things that are
different and you know the picture and
and who wouldn't wanna and to me it's
like who wouldn't wanna I haven't done
it yeah I'm curious haven't anyway
you've got 23 whatever thoughts but like
one why no 50 K or 50 mile or or a trail
you know something else I think it's
because for some reason I'd fallen into
this phone down this rabbit hole of like
of numbers and speed and right it's at
first it was like qualified for boss and
then Wow let's see if I can still get
but here's the thing see this is from a
very Bob Larson perspective this is why
you need to you need to shake it up like
you need to get off like what he would
call the track like yeah if you get off
that you're so wed to these numbers and
holding yourself to account for these
performance goals you might actually be
able to crash through this Plateau by by
you know doing something completely
different that's longer where it's not
about numbers and then return to the
marathon in a year or two or whatever
with a refreshed perspective on it and I
would I would venture to bet that you
would see a big
it's game I think you're right and I'd
like to try it and I just and it's like
it's then it's one of those it's
probably the thing that lately and a
bunch of like friends that I know who do
them and keep asking me about it as well
it's lately become the thing that a I'm
afraid of be I'm starting to think about
a little too much see what I'm afraid of
something and I'm thinking about a lot I
know I'm gonna have to try it at some
point so you're gonna have to get
comfortable without desire I'm gonna be
so it's there is an is 50 K he think a
good distance to start out I would I
would I would but I would urge you to go
like find a trail race you know just do
something totally I really want to do a
trail marathon yeah there's one outside
Chicago but to forget about the marathon
do like do something where you can't
it's just so apples and oranges yeah but
it gets you out of that paradigm that
you're in okay let's do it yeah all
right I'm ready commit I'm ready you're
committing right I got a ratty all right
it's on the record it's on the record
I'm fine I'll do I'll juice five to a
trail run have you have you ever covered
the 3,100 do you know the Sri Chinmoy
run and Queens I I know about it but I
start I think it starts in June it might
have might have already started I don't
know right I know about seen pictures of
them doing it so no I've never I've
never could just that it just go out
there and check it out I had Sanjay
Rawal on who made a documentary called
30 100 run and become I think you would
enjoy it follows a couple different
people but in particular one guy who's
like I think he's from Finland I can't
remember but he's like a mailman and he
does this race every year and they
literally run around this one-mile Block
in Queens until they've reached 31 is
open from 6:00 a.m. to midnight every
day they run as much as they can every
day they go to sleep they come back the
next day I just keep doing it and
there's just something so bananas and
fascinating and beautiful and insane
about the whole thing
that is the ultra that I definitely will
not be but maybe just take a subway ride
out there and watch for an afternoon
right yeah yeah that's that's that's
that's what I was worried in New York
Times today you guys haven't I'm sure
you've covered that race in the past the
paper yes we definitely have I will say
the one thing about trail running that
does make me nervous is a one of your
college classmates Peter Graff
laughter last year he was 2017 I was out
in Boulder and I'd never been on the
Mesa trail and I wanted to run on the
Mesa Trail and Peter's kind of an insane
trail runner no I didn't know that I was
like yeah I got a uh I got him you know
an interview at 10:00 so I'm your 10:30
I'll meet you I'll come by your house it
he's like sure come by in the morning
we'll go uh-huh and like two hours and
15 minutes later gonna work I'm
stumbling down a mesa trail with
butyrate he's I was I mean I was tired
yes but the main thing I was afraid of
was losing my front teeth so that's part
of the fear of the trail run is the
tripping over the roots and the rock but
you're working like different muscles
that's a different discipline you're
shaking it up and it's making you
stronger in areas that don't get worked
just running the loop in Central Park
absolutely and you're not looking at
your Garmin worried about your pace
because it doesn't matter right it's
completely it's completely separate from
it no I totally I am totally with it
intellectually the one thing I don't
want to do is I don't want to carry my
water uh-huh I don't want it I don't
like that whole self-supporting idea on
the bat and the backpack I have no I
just from an aesthetic point of view or
just honestly from a sort of flow point
of view like I mean part of the reason I
love running is I love this sort of
feeling of being liberated and
unencumbered and the idea of having a
pack on my back and running seems
unpleasant but you could just do the
little waist drop with a one bottle or
something like that you'll get used to
it yeah okay you're gonna acclimate to
it all right
cool well I want to close this down with
one one final thing which
your thoughts on running culture like
the book is about the rebellious Ness
the kind of rock and roll
you know sensibility that accompanied
this you know burst this this you know
new kind of revelation that took place
as a result of Larson's work how do you
think about running culture now like is
it still you know Knox Robinson said you
know running is an act of rebellion and
I've heard you say something similar
like is that still the case like how do
we connect with that rebellious 'no snow
when it is such a mainstream you know
Lululemon type of activity I think the
biggest evolution that running has
undergone certainly in the last 15-20
years is that it has really gone from
being a solitary activity to a group of
a group activity when I'm running in
Central Park there were plenty of
runners in the 90s in Central Park
but now there are just these clumps you
just everybody is running seemingly with
a group and not everybody but a lot of
people and you just keep passing these
clumps and everybody's talking to each
other and it's it's a really social
thing and I think that's terrific
because I know the performance benefits
of it and I know that if you're making
plans to run Thursday you're a lot more
likely to skip it if you don't have to
meet someone on the corner of 81st and
3rd at 6:00 in the morning so so that's
the sort of that that is sort of where
running culture is right now and yes
it's mainstream but I do continue to
think that even though there's hundreds
of thousands of people who line up on
the start line of marathons every year
that's still a pretty small fraction of
the population and most people when you
say to them yeah I'm running
next Saturday or run in Boston in a
month
most people say wow that's amazing
you're crazy
and that's a real kick for me I know it
is and I think it's a real kick for a
lot of people that you that that that
idea that this is still yes it's
mainstream but it's to a lot of people
it's still a little it's a little nuts
and it still feels a little rebellious
it still feels like you're sort of
cheating is the wrong word but you're
doing something you're doing something
different that's one of the reasons the
Boston Marathon is so great because it
takes place on a Monday and the entire
rest of the world is at work working and
this is Monday morning and all of Boston
is is off for the day essentially you
know yes it's Patriots day but what is
Patriots Day even essentially it's a
marathon day uh-huh and it just feels
like you're playing hooky from life and
dialing into that sort of playing hooky
from life thing on a daily run is
something that's still possible and
still certainly brings me a great deal
of joy and I think brings a lot of
people Elijah white yeah I think it's
freedom it's sort of railing against the
gestalt of time and gravity there's
something about it that is uniquely
liberating that I don't feel when I'm
riding a bike
I mean riding bike is amazing for
different reasons and swimming as well
but there's something specific about
running that I don't get or find in
either other endurance pursuits that I
can't quite put my finger on but it does
feel nonetheless like an act of
rebellion for some strange reason even
though everyone's doing it or not
everyone but a lot of people and not
having the answer is probably the best
thing right I think if you if you are to
articulate about the answer you haven't
thought deeply enough about it maybe
right and then you'll
of stopping right because the search
will be over that's right and who wants
that yeah nobody wants that I want to
run as long as I possibly can basically
so thank you
that's fantastic thanks so much for
having any running to the edge is the
book congratulations you were named by
Time magazine like one of the reads you
got to read this summer one of the 32
must reads for this stuff
exactly recall those I'm scrolling
through it I think it was pretty high in
the list I don't know if they ranked
them in a particular order but showed up
pretty soon yeah I'm not supposed to
mention this I should say like it comes
out at the beginning of the summer and
in with it was like by release date and
alphabetical so that's what I think put
me ahead of Elizabeth no break right
it's okay but I think I was fourth on
the list and amy was very pleased with
that
all right cool so what did we learn here
a couple things one you're gonna sign up
for some Trail 50k I need to run with
groups more I'm such a solo guy so
that's actually a change that I'm gonna
make as a result of talking you in
reading this book and third next time
I'm in New York let's go running
absolutely deal
absolutely and I'm gonna keep up all
this running and adventure coverage in
the New York Times yeah keep please
please continue to expand that it's been
great to be able to read more and more
about these more obscure athletes and
the fact that you're introducing them
you know in the grandest way possible to
the world is a really cool thing so I
commend you for that Thanks all right
man thanks so much for having me all
right Matthew peace
[Music]